[Applauso]
Buonasera
tutto ciò che vive a un orizzonte e
l'orizzonte che rende vita la vita senza
un orizzonte La vita è una cosa morta
l'utopia concreta concreta capite non
sono fantasmagorie di filosofi e poeti
l'utopia è sempre qualcosa di concreto
storico reale sta all'orizzonte di ogni
realtà
l'utopia non è fuga nell'irreale è scavo
come una talpa per la messa in luce
delle possibilità oggettive insite nel
reale e lotta per la loro realizzazione
Queste sono parole di Ernst Block che un
filosofo il filosofo dell'utopia ha
scritto spirito del utopia il principio
speranza e quando parliamo di utopia
propriamente l'utopia è questo ed è solo
questo è una forza immanente alla storia
degli umani degli umani nel loro insieme
e la forza dell'esodo verso la Terra
promessa una forza collettiva che spinge
gli uomini nella loro interezza nella
loro rete di relazionalità verso
l'orizzonte l'orizzonte è una roba che
non raggiungeremo mai Noi ci avviciniamo
e quello se ne va più in là come la
tartaruga di Zenone
è però se non avessimo l'orizzonte la
vita sarebbe una cosa morta e noi saremo
sempre fermi
ed è la storia che ce lo insegna
Io insegno storia e filosofia o
filosofia e storia una volta Parlavo
della lotta per l'indipendenza dei Greci
contro l'impero Ottomano stiamo parlando
del decennio del 20 dell'800
e raccontavo come tantissimi giovani da
tutta Europa andassero in Grecia per
condividere quella realissima utopia di
quella realissima lotta per la Libertà
uno studente
intervenne e mi disse Beh bello però
queste cose oggi non potrebbero mai
succedere questo è proprio un altro
mondo
prima che io che so li raccontassi che
poco tempo prima ero stato con i
guerriglieri e le guerrigliere curvie
curde nella Pianura deserte che era kena
là dove passava il confine con l'isis a
pochi chilometri e un condividendo con
questi curdi e curve la loro lotta e con
loro c'erano tanti ragazzi che venivano
da tutto il mondo per condividere quella
lotta esattamente come in Grecia prima
che io facessi questo
intervenne un'altra ragazza dice Beh
però non ti ricordi quel ragazzo di cui
ci ha parlato la professoressa di
religione non ero stato io quella volta
a parlargli di Vittorio Arrigoni
Vittorio Arrigoni era un ragazzo che se
ne era andato dalla Brianza
sperando di condividere un'utopia
concreta che è sempre collettiva di
giustizia e di libertà e lui se ne era
andato in una terra prigioniera come
gasa attraversando il mare e lì ha
trovato la morte quel giovane uomo dalla
Brianza era partito e si era dato un
nome al nome nuovo il nome Nuovo di
Vittoria Rigoni era proprio utopia
e l'utopia che è necessaria In un mondo
che non sa più pensare un altro mondo
possibile quel ragazzo quello studente
aveva detto Beh queste sono cose del
passato perché ha imparato una frase che
sta alla base di questo nostro mondo
alternative non c'è alternativa a questo
mondo lo aveva detto una signora che era
Margaret Thatcher e lei aveva detto
un'altra frase che strettamente
interrellata con questa ovvero aveva
detto non esiste la società
esistono solo gli individui
le due cose stanno maledettamente
insieme non sappiamo immaginare un altro
mondo possibile la forza dell'utopia
perché siamo in una società di individui
questo però non non ce ne accorgiamo
che questo mondo è un mondo che
pretende
di includere ogni possibilità
e quindi non è possibile immaginare
pensare un altro mondo possibile se ogni
possibilità è già qui
i tre comandamenti di questo mondo sono
tre clienti pubblicitarie
uno è Just Do It
devi solo farlo
tutto è lì dipende da te
fallo devi produrre il tuo successo Sì
performativo sì prestazionale produci te
stesso si imprenditore di te stesso vai
l'altro claim è Impossible is nothing
l'azienda avversaria della prima non
esiste l'impossibile Tutto dipende da te
devi meritarlo il merito tu sei
responsabile e se non ce la fai a
prendere quello che vuoi in questo
oceano di possibilità
infinite che è il nostro mondo
la colpa è solo tua la responsabilità è
solo tua sei tu il fallito sei tu il
loser sei tu lo sfigato
ti soverchiano per tutta la vita questi
claim come dei comandamenti come dei
mantra ripetuti continuamente e il terzo
clima comporre questa Trinità
tutto intorno a te
tutto intorno a te tu sei il centro del
mondo Questa è la società lo sappiamo
bene Non è più la società delle edicole
società del Narciso che intorno a sé non
altro che specchio in cui vede riflessa
la propria immagine e non sa più dire
nulla all'altro perché l'altro non è
altro che la propria immagine riflessa
che lo conferma
E allora noi bisogna scavare perché
diceva error's Block bisogna scavare le
possibilità che stanno nel reale e
bisogna scavare nella sofferenza che
produce questa questa situazione perché
e comandamenti sono questi Beh che cosa
succede che tu sei
freneticamente iperattivo Non c'è un
minuto da perdere per produrre te stesso
per essere all'altezza di quegli
standard
prestazionali quelle asticelle che si
alzano continuamente no dicevano prima
in questa società non c'è spazio per la
ricerca personale devi sempre produrre
No quest'anno a scuola c'è questa bella
novità che
ogni studente sarà chiamato a fare il
suo capolavoro
La ricerca la sperimentazione
senza scopo per sperimentare se stessi
perché non devi essere sempre produttivo
ma il comandamento è quello sì
imprenditore di te stesso e allora non
c'è un minuto da perdere devi fare fare
fare fare fare fare produrre e poi però
inevitabilmente arriva il down no
viviamo viviamo in una sinusoide l'app
questa eccitazione maniacale in cui
siamo immersi Finché poi arriva il senso
di inedeguatezza inevitabile
la depressione la depressione L'uomo in
panne L'uomo che non ce la fa più che si
scopre impotente che si scopre
inadeguato non ce la faccio non posso
più sostenere Questa pressione e crollo
e schianto Ecco il fallimento il
fallimento è l'incubo generazionale e
l'incubo di chi è nato in questa società
performativa degli individui del
narcisismo
il fallimento che non è questa cosa come
dire così essenziale all'umano no c'è
una frase meravigliosa di Samuel Beckett
che dice ho sempre provato ho sempre
fallito non importa
Proverò ancora fallirò ancora
fallirò meglio
fallire è necessario nella vita perché
fallire significa sperimentare se stessi
creare se stessi sperimentare la propria
potenza il proprio campo di possibilità
la propria potenza ad agire di Red
Spinoza ma questo non è possibile perché
il fallimento non è sostenibile il
fallimento equivale uno schianto perché
le frustrazioni sono insostenibili e
intollerabili per degli individui che
sono stati sottoposti continuamente
delle ingiunzioni di essere all'altezza
dell'immagine perfetta di se e di ciò
che il mondo ti chiede E allora crolli
schianti
come piantata quella ragazza a 19 anni
qualche mese fa Inu si è suicidata in un
bagno dell'università a Milano lasciando
un biglietto la mia vita è stata un
fallimento è stata a 19 anni un
fallimento quanto ingiunzioni
performative a essere a produrre essere
imprenditrice di se stesso questa
ragazza deve avere ricevuto nella sua
vita
ma lo stesso movimento lo fanno
quelle sofferenze che dilagano in questo
mondo No pensate
l'anoressia pensate il ritiro sociale la
Fobia sociale tutte forme di rottura
della relazione col mondo
io mi richiudo nel mio corpo prigione io
Mi rinchiudo nella mia camera prigione
che diventa una nicchia ecologica di
sopravvivenza per sottrarsi a quel mondo
che ti fa male
Ma i ragazzi non sono solo quelli che
soffrono i ragazzi sono quelli che sanno
queste cose molto bene che hanno una
consapevolezza quest'inverno proprio
Hanno occupato delle scuole un fatto
rivoluzionario la prima volta che è
successo Hanno occupato delle scuole a
Milano per dire basta a questo modo di
fare scuola questo modo di fare società
per sottrarsi per rivendicare la propria
salute mentale per mettere in comune le
proprie sofferenze psichiche
Questo è un fatto rivoluzionario come i
ragazzi che parlano sui social e non
hanno più vergogna a parlare delle
proprie sofferenze psichiche perché qui
bisogna scavare per portare la luce
dell'utopia
io ho studiato diversi anni queste cose
ovviamente essendo uno scrittore c'è
scritto libro ma è se dovessi dire una
frase per
sintetizzare tutto questo è soffro
Dunque siamo io soffro Ma se scavo in
questa mia sofferenza trovo che questa
sofferenza e qualche cosa che mi
connette a tutti gli altri quindi lì io
posso ritrovare la forza esotica
dell'utopia che la forza esotica è una
forza collettiva e connettiva io faccio
la rivoluzione quando parlo con gli
altri quando mi confronto con gli altri
quando sento che le mie sofferenze non
sono solo mie del mio privato
addirittura del mio cervello sono
sofferenze che riguardano tutti quanti
hanno da dire hanno da parlare noi tutti
quanti dobbiamo farne parola Ecco allora
che la presenza di Vittoria Rigoni fa
luce a chi pensa che non ci sia
un'alternativa possibile e allora chiudo
cantando cantandovi una canzone che
scrissi
qualche anno fa proprio dedicata a
Vittorio Arrigoni che si chiamava
utopia e aveva scritto una lettera poco
prima di morire dicendo che avrebbe
voluto raccontare l'utopia di quei
ragazzi a casa e quella è l'utopia di
quei ragazzi a casa e vivere una vita
normale perché vivono nella prigione e
loro una vita normale non riescono mai a
viverla
[Musica]
per vedere il mare in Brianza ci vuole
cuore e tanta fantasia
e tu che avevi il nome di utopia vedevi
il cielo dentro la tua stanza
e il cielo aperto che cade nel mare e il
mare lo sa di non avere confini i
confini sono roba di piccola gente che
vive per poco e muore per niente
per vedere ciò che non si vede bisogna
avere fede e coraggio la Fede che
qualcosa deve accadere il coraggio che
chiede di poterlo vedere e la tua utopia
ha preso il Largo a vent'anni ha scelto
l'aperto del mare o del cielo che poi è
lo stesso concetto che qui c'è un mondo
da fare e la tua utopia è arrivata in
barca a casa e lì ha preso casa in
quella striscia di terra senza aria c'è
bisogno di respirare
navigare navigare mani ferme sul timone
con il sole sulla faccia barra dritta
utopia navigare navigare con le ali di
gabbiano nei bandiere né frontiere il
mare è di chi resta umano
le bombe cadevano bruciavano i corpi
fiorivano gli incubi al cielo del cielo
il piombo fuso colava la gente crepava e
non c'era misura per questo scempio per
questo massacro portato ad esempio al
mondo intero e allora scrivevi per farne
figura per toglier paura al mondo intero
dicevi dei segni lasciati nei sogni dei
bimbi dei visi scalfiti da rughe dei
vecchi che hanno visto due nachba e
aspetta alla morte così come ha vissuto
e ha vissuto in gabbia e tu in quella
gabbia sei voluto tornare in nave per
mare in migliaia al porto ad aspettare
le prime navi dal 67 e il tuo mare
racconta c'è da raccontare che cosa si
vuole dopo quel terrore e non è
difficile immaginare che si vuole una
vita normale
navigare navigare mani ferme sul timone
con il sole sulla faccia sbarra dritta
utopia navigare navigare con le ali di
gabbiano nei bandiere né frontiere il
mare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie